[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this episode
were breaking down the Little Mermaid's
worst nightmare underwater throughout
this video we'll be discussing the ins
and outs of the movie as well as its
ending and how it teases a sequel there
will be heavy spoilers here itself II
don't anything runed and I highly
suggest that you turn off now make sure
you subscribe to the channel for
breakdowns like this every day
and without the way I just want to give
a huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of
underwater
underwater follows the doomed crew of
the Kepler 8 to 2 station a team tasked
by conglomerate t in industries to drill
for resources in the Mariana Trench if
you've seen alien life or a handful of
other sci-fi horror movies of the same
ilk then from the off you know what to
expect we're underwater tries to differ
slightly from its inspirations is that
instead keeps the elements of horror
contained on our own planet most namely
the undiscovered areas of the ocean the
opening of the movie has a collage of
text that showcases some of teen
industry's explorations and how they had
disastrous consequences in the text on
screen we can see mention of high-risk
jobs and rumors of sightings and the
vastness of the ocean these were covered
up by the corporation and this plays
massively into the end of the movie and
shows that thien though aware of what's
going on down there don't show any signs
of stopping what they're doing this is
where we are introduced to Nora Price
played by Kristen Stewart and the rest
of a team the catastrophic breach hits
the station due to the apparent
pressures of the depths of the ocean and
this is pretty much the springboard for
the film's plot the crew must do
whatever they can to escape the station
and make it out of the murky depths of
the darkness that surrounds them unlike
the movies that came before it
underwater doesn't really have all that
much set up it really throws you in at
the deep end pun intended and because of
this I found the movie to be instantly
engaging if you like me then being
adrift in open water has always seemed
far more terrifying than the thought of
being adrift in space there's just
something about being stuck in the ocean
unable to see what's lurking down there
even with the monsters that the crew
come across I think this film still
would have terrified me just because of
the saying there's a real sense of
claustrophobia from the outset and even
watching Nora brush your teeth in the
movies introduction has a tense feeling
to it there's a moment where the
pressure of the ocean alone kills a
character by cracking his helmet wide
open that hammers home that in this
perilous environment death can come at
any second after the disastrous tear
that starts the movie with a splash Nora
and another survivor Roderigo are forced
to trap some of the crew
water in order to save themselves and
instantly it grounds the movie with the
notion that this is every man a woman
for themselves this has made ever more
clear when Nora Rodrigo and Paul played
by TJ Miller crawl to an escape pod Bay
only to find that all of them have been
deployed this notion of fighting for
your own survival no matter the cost
comes into play massively towards the
end of the movie and is pretty much the
defining arc that Nora goes on she
realizes that sometimes you have to make
a sacrifice for the greater good in
order so that others can survive we can
see in the introduction of the movie
that price is difficulty in putting
herself before others but she still does
it this is exemplified by the scene in
which he trapped are the survivors under
the water but eventually this comes full
circle with a life once more being on
the line but she goes the opposite way
price Rodrigo and Paul slowly reunite
with the other survivors including
Captain Lucian and eventually they
reached the control base which is where
they realized that if they're gonna make
it out of this they're gonna have to
push themselves to the extremes to get
out of the area and back to safety they
must put on pressurized suits and walk
one mile across the ocean floor to an
abandoned neighboring station named at
Robert 641 it turns out that this is the
station we saw in the introduction that
ended up having a similar disaster to
the Keppler now this wouldn't be much of
a monster movie without any monsters and
these come in the form of several deep
sea creatures that clearly had a hand in
the destruction of the station they
discover a hatchling and a corpse that
they come across and this sort of adds a
facehugger element to the film and as
they make their way to the ocean floor
they are slowly hunted by the monsters
it's as scary as you'd expect and the
film does a brilliant job of making you
care for the characters even though they
don't have a crazy amount of screen time
or character development I think under
waters strongest element is definitely
its pacing it's fast constantly moving
and it doesn't give you time to catch
your breath I'd stopped doing the water
puns but what are you gonna do about it
yeah no that's a dislike button get away
from there now I will stop I promise the
movie has an incredible since soundtrack
and it really makes underwater a fun
time I'm surprised it's got a January
release
because it's way better than the month
that most movies go to you today as for
the monsters themselves they come in all
shapes and sizes
from the tiny hatchlings to the humanoid
size creatures that litter the ocean
floor all the way up to the gigantic
beasts that we discover have been
attacking the stations these seem to be
what most of the smaller creatures
gravitate around and they have an almost
parasitic and symbiotic relationship
with a larger version of the species
from what we see in the film the smaller
ones have nests and price at one point
comes across a group of these are
sleeping they are able to stealthily
sneak up on people due to their
environments and are adept at swimming
they are highly attracted to light and
thus navigating your way through that
terrain is very very difficult there's a
lip service pay to the fact that they
live in a hydrothermal pocket which is
able to provide them with heat in order
to survive the coldness of the deep
either way they're scary as hell and
this ain't no mermen mer man basically
imagine coming face to face with the
monsters of the trench but you don't
have the powers of Aquaman that's what
this movie feels like and it's awesome
because of it the crew that make it
through the descent and there isn't that
many begin the walk across the ocean
floor lurking behind them is another
Christian that slowly stalks them and
drags one of the group away Lucian
chases after him and he's dragged
himself price goes after him and his
drag too but Lucian sacrifices himself
in order for her to escape I think this
kind of shows that sometimes you must
make the tough call and Lucian was a man
who but others above his own safety he
remarks about going down with his ship
early in the movie and you really get
the feeling that he has a sense of duty
price says he should ignore this because
he has a family but still he makes the
tough decision now I have a theory that
this is because he was actually aware of
the creatures much in the same way that
thien were upon arriving at another
station they discovered that he worked
there and after seeing the movie for a
second time there are clues that he had
prior knowledge of what was in the deep
this is based off his reactions and so
on but yeah I feel like the clues are
there clearly survived the first attack
a nurse probably feels like he should
have died in that one who knows what he
went through but either way he's been
through this situation before it
indicates that his sacrifice may have
been because he feels
sponsible for what he led the crew into
and there is some element of guilt there
the three survivors that make the walk
price Havisham and Smith get to the
Roebuck but they discover a giant
creature wrapped around the station this
is clearly the one that killed the crew
in the attack mentioned in the
introduction and it looks like the
creatures have infested the outside of
the station the survivors rushed to the
three escape pods but unfortunately only
two are functional price puts the others
before herself convincing them to take
the life rafts up to the surface during
their ascension the gigantic creature
emerges from the outer shell of the
Roebuck and we can see countless
creatures hanging from it they swim
towards the to escape pods and the giant
begins to ravage the station price makes
the ultimate sacrifice and raises the
core levels of the station causing it to
explode and kill the surrounding
monsters it's a turn that I wasn't
really expecting mainly because I've
gotten so used to the final girl trope
in horror movies but this was a really
nice change up the to get away and it
should be a happy ending but we learned
that teen industries once more covered
up the disaster they silenced Havisham
and Smith by denying them access to
interviews and destroy the camera
footage and tried to censor everything
about the outbreak the movie ends with
TN announcing that they're planning to
expand their drilling efforts which is
clearly hinting at a sequel with crews
disappearing one by one
I can see suspicions mounting up around
the company and the further they dive
into the deep the more likely they are
to discover bigger and more terrifying
creatures I'm glad that they didn't go
down the route of the the corporation
wants to capture the creatures to sell
em but clearly they have little care
over the life of their staff we don't
really know the time setting of the film
or what the world's really like at this
point but if they're having to dive this
deep then we can assume that natural
resources are a little supply and the
steen wants to go further into the
depths no matter the cost of human life
even though we know that they are diving
too deep it seems that they don't care
and will do whatever they can to make
sure they have a supply chain if there
is to be a sequel I can see it being set
further in the depths with us
discovering more about the ins and outs
of the monsters as well as their homes
I'm definitely interested in seeing a
follow up in this movie massively
surprised me
I wasn't expecting much but I left the
film enjoying it and it's
home atmosphere and soundscape really
elevated above others underwater doesn't
reinvent the wheel but it does a lot
with what it has and the premise is
interesting enough to warrant a rewatch
if you haven't seen underwater then I
definitely recommend that you give it a
chance and that's why it gets an 8 out
of 10
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on underwater and if you want
to see a sequel or not comment below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of this weekend's are the big
release 1917 which is gonna be linked at
the end we go over everything you need
to know about the film and why it has
the perfect ending I think it's one of
the best videos I've ever done so
definitely check it out if you want
something else to watch after this if
you want to come chat to me after the
video then make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey or head
over to my discord server which would be
linked in the description below we drop
videos on there early so if you want to
see stuff before anyone else and that's
the best place to be it's free adjoining
we have an awesome community so
hopefully we see over there very soon
we're also giving away a free copy of
Joker which is one of our favorite
movies of the last year and all you have
to do to be in with a chance of winning
is like the video make sure you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts an underwater in the comment
section below
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of January and the cell be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprised so best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is a channel for
people who are mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe huge thank you for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best now see you next time take care
peace
you